So have a look at the clip of this video
here. This is an animation but see if you
can think about it in another way.
There we go.
So given the choice which you
think is the more friendly object?
Hands up for green.
Hands up for yellow square.
It's amazing really! It's just an animation yet we
think of these things as having personalities.
In fact babies when they watched this were
given the choice between a square and a
triangle and when they saw the square
being helpful they prefer to play with
the square object. So these babies are interpreting
them and giving them rich personalities.
From the very beginning we
see the world as populated with others
who are acting with goals and intentions.
We even apply that reasoning to
inanimate objects. I mean do you ever
speak to your toys or if you have a
computer do you get frustrated and shout
at it when it crashes?
You say "Don't crash! I haven't saved my homework!"
You know this is exactly what we do we give
inanimate objects these qualities to
make it easier to interact with them.
It's another way that our brain is
making assumptions about the world and
adding extra information.
Movement provides not only a rich source of what
someone is like but a channel of
communication where no words are exchanged.